marry here with a news update
CD Projekt RED once again flies in the
face of major publishers announcing
today that anyone who purchases The
Witcher 3 will get 16 DLC packs for free
the first pack will be released the day
after the game comes out on February
24th it contains an armor set as well as
new hairstyles for Geralt
nice beard 2 DLC bundles will be
released weekly after that until all 16
packs are released including alternative
looks for other main characters such as
yennefer as well as new quests the
reasoning behind giving out all the DLC
for free was given by the CD Projekt RED
co-founder in an open letter to fans as
gamers we nowadays have to hold on tight
to our wallet as surprisingly right
after release lots of tiny pieces of
tempting content materialized with a
steep price tag attached haven't we just
paid a lot of cash for a brand new game
as CD Projekt RED we strongly believe
this is not the way it should work and
with The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt we have
decided to do it differently this is our
way of saying thank you for buying our
game he goes on to say that this is not
a pre-order bonus you get the DLC if you
buy before or after the release date
it's also not limited to the collector's
edition or physical copies every copy of
the game gets you a free ride on the DLC
train choo-choos not that we need any
more reasons to anticipate The Witcher 3
pretty sure we're all excited about it
for more gaming news
I recommend gamespot.com slash news
nice beard